in canada there is anger over those
vaccine mandates it's led to escalating
protests by truckers including at the
border with the u.s now this is day two
of a blockade at a bridge carrying about
a quarter of american trade with canada
there are now signs there could soon be
similar protests in this country janet
samlion is in ottawa where canadian
officials are struggle to maintain the
order it's very dicey there janet good
morning to you
indeed it is gail good morning to you it
is a tangled mess of big rigs and
barricades here on the streets of
canada's capitol near parliament this
morning it has been like this for almost
two weeks now and the truckers who are
here and the other protesters who have
joined them say they have no plans to
leave
how long have you been out here i have
actually been out here since last
saturday monty who did not want to share
his last name is one of hundreds of
truckers blocking the roads around
parliament in canada's capital city
demanding an end to vaccine mandates
we're going to sit here as long as it
takes
the problem is they don't want to talk
to us right now take a look at all these
big rigs
it goes down this street and on a number
of other streets all over
the center section the parliament
section of ottawa with the streets
blocked about the only supplies coming
in are from volunteers what are you
doing out here we're just happy to
support the truckers and you know we
know a lot of people are doing donations
of canned foods and stuff so we wanted
to make some homemade fresh food with
love as downtown ottawa remains
paralyzed the city's mayor says he needs
another 1800 police officers to keep the
peace we are turning up the heat in
every way we possibly can it has to stop
and canadian prime minister justin
trudeau condemned the protest accusing
them of undermining canadian democracy
people of ottawa don't deserve to be
harassed in their own neighborhoods as
support from anti-vaccine and far-right
groups around the world is growing
the costs are mounting from the threat
to the major supply chain connecting
canada to the u.s to the local
businesses closed in ottawa to the
trucker's bottom line what type of toll
is that taking on your income
an absolute toll i have no income
but they already took that for him from
me before i got here
we need to keep
this country free
trudeau says he is not willing to meet
with the protesters but the mayor of
ottawa is floating the idea now of
bringing in a federal mediator meanwhile
there are social media posts this
morning indicating that similar protest
is being planned in the united states it
would be a large convoy from sacramento
all the way to washington d.c
vlad
all right to be continued janet thank
you very much